hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and you know in this video I want to
cover a question that I get quite often
you know a lot of people ask me Mike
what is your favorite order flow setup
and you know honestly there are many
setups that I look for in the market but
one that's sort of my you know my great
white whale so to speak that when I see
it you know it just gets me super
excited
um that it's an automatic trade problem
is it doesn't appear every day
um sometimes you may go a couple days
without seeing it but it is when it does
appear you know it's a very powerful
signal so you know today we had this is
the 10-year notes it's just a simple
five minute chart nothing special with
the footprint on it and you know we
ripped up
to the upside um you know when the CPI
print came up came out and you know we
started making this high at the 115 11
then you know about 30 minutes later 40
minutes 45 minutes later we poked up and
made a new high here at uh what was that
11 and a half okay so we just made a new
high here at around 8 15 on this five
minute chart and then later in the
session let me just expand this up a bit
here
uh we came back and tested that high
okay but what was interesting on this
retest
first time we hit that high right it
traded a lot of volume up there uh once
that volume was like 813 I'm looking at
the volume on the offer side okay you
actually went bid over there for about
320. and then the market
started
drifting lower I don't say sold off
because you know even though it did drop
from 11 down to 01
um you know that initial bar at 8 15.
you know that was the entire range those
drifting down and then it came back up
to retest that high and as we're
retesting that high now again this is at
nine o'clock in the morning Chicago time
when we made that high that was around 8
15 I mean earlier we did you know this
was a new high by one tick after the CPI
came out so
um you know this is it's in normal
trading hours but the second time we
came up to this High what was
getting me all hot and flustered all
excited about was the volumes when we
came back up there right this is a
double top but it's a double top and you
traded one contract at the high of the
day right it's it's um you know earlier
you traded you know close to over a
thousand contracts the second time you
get up there you can only muster one
contract
and when I see that one contract like I
said you don't see this every day
especially if you're looking at you know
five minute chart or 15 minute chart of
a footprint but when you see it you know
that just screams out to you that buyers
are done and this was a very important
lesson
um that I learned from Tom DeMark many
many years ago back in the 90s when I
was working at Dean Witter I went to one
of his
um trainings and he said you know when
the last buyer bought the moves over
just as you know on a move down when the
last seller sells the move is over and
it's never been more clear than when you
look at a footprint chart because you
see that just one contract
when you retest the high where are your
buyers you're not going to go any higher
even you know as you're coming back up I
mean it's not like this volume is you
know so pathetic it's traded 20 000
contracts in this five minute bar which
is more than the previous bar than the
previous bar than the previous bar than
the previous bar so the volume is
healthy it's not like it's trading you
know up here at this high on very light
volume it's got solid volume going up
there I mean you can see the volumes
um you know on the offer below it it's
1400 below that's 3 300 below that is
four thousand so a strong offers going
up there but what's happened is the
buyers have weakened right they're just
not interested anymore and then what
happens when there's no more interest in
buying
well then the sellers start coming in
right and then in the bar afterwards you
see strong negative Delta minus 1400
next bar more negative Delta but the the
most obvious sign is this one contract
that traded there I mean it's like the
market is screaming to you that there's
no more buyers you know there's no more
people that want to take it higher
anymore
and what happens that's your high right
is this a double top it's a retest of
that double top
less volume the second time and you see
the market start selling off from you
know you're not gonna get short
initially on this bar you gotta wait
till it closes right make sure you know
we're not going back up in this bar
um you know you're getting short at 0808
and a half or nine
and over the next 30 minutes it trades
all the way down below the figure 115
all right I mean and you know it's more
or less going sideways in here but sort
of trending down obviously it did break
um lower down into the 20s but you know
this is sort of the issue that you're
going to run into trading 10 years you
get it this is a grinding Market
sometimes right it's it's not you know
not every day you get those moves that
you see AF that we hit after the CPI
um oftentimes it's it's just sort of
like this the slow grind down but this
was just so obvious and again you know
if you use a longer time frame on a
footprint you know normally I use a one
minute chart as well as a five minute
chart but you can look at you know you
just put on another screen put a five
minute chart up of bonds 10 years
um you know e-minis and yes you know
contracts that trade a lot of volume
right I mean look at these volumes right
it's normally trading in the thousands
but just one contract created there just
as as it's dropping lower or you see two
contracts one contract seven contracts
you know at the top of These Bars
there's just no more buying interest
there's just not
creators just aren't interested in
taking it higher anymore so
you know if if I had to
you know if someone put a uh you know
said Mike you know what is the one trade
that you're going to look for you know I
would look for you know at the highs or
the lows of the day
very minimal volume right one contract
two contracts three contracts trading at
the low or at the highest because that's
telling me that you know the last buyer
has bought or the last seller has sold
honestly probably what this was this one
contract is people were trying you know
we're coming back up to the high and
it's probably you know some
some guy you know some Trader I don't
see some guy you know it could be a
woman
um
testing it to see if they could you know
trade it to attract other buyers to come
in or you know maybe trigger some stops
or something because it is the high of
the day but there's nobody else
interested right it's like
um you know anytime you're going up to a
high or you're going to take out a high
sometimes the market is Bid you know
like here was bid earlier at the high
right so it's bid and and the offer was
one tick above the high but nobody
bought that one to probe it but as
you're coming back this one could have
either been somebody you know the last
buyer buying or maybe somebody trying to
trade it to get you know the computer
systems to also start to trade it but
the fact is nobody traded it right
that's the important thing is just one
person traded it that was it couldn't go
any higher Market started reversing off
that that's your sign then you start
adding in the next bar two selling
imbalances right strong negative Delta
next bar strong negative Delta point of
control is moving lower from the bar at
the High second bar is lower third bar
is lower
the next bar so it's higher but it's you
know it's a green candle but it tests
that same point of control from two bars
earlier and then the sell-off continues
selling a balance silent balance selling
a balance you know two lots all right we
open up and there's just no more buying
interest right that's what you often see
you know on moves down is at the top of
the bars in volume
and you know which sort of leads me into
this this next point is you know a lot
of people think that you know order flow
is about you know watching where the big
volumes come in right everyone uses
um that uses a dome or or trades on a
book map or a heat map rather they're
always looking for the areas of
liquidity where there's big volumes
but
when you have periods of
very little volume or prices that trade
very little volume that's also very
important don't disregard that don't
think I don't like two contracts traded
that that doesn't mean anything no it's
very important on a market that's
trading twenty thousand seven hundred
contracts in this bar and at that high
you only trade one contract
Okay so
you know if
he said if if I only had a basic
footprint with no other tools on there
other than just you know the bid ask
foot the bid ask volumes you know and
point of control
you know and imbalances right going back
to you know 20
12 2013 2014.
um you know before you know some more
advances were made in the order flow
chart that's what I'd look for and
that's what I did look for right I mean
I remember taking trades like this in in
British pounds on 15 minute charts right
it would spike up there trade one
contract and then start to slowly drift
down it's just a sign of lack of buying
interest at the high of the day
okay so again you know just remember
it's not necessarily only about watching
where heavy volume comes in it's also
about paying attention to areas of very
very light volume or next to no volume I
don't want to say no volume because then
it wouldn't trade but you know when
you're seeing one contract two contracts
three contracts go through then that's
something that you know you should also
pay attention to and try to understand
why it's happening that's the whole
point of using order flows to try to
understand what's happening in the
market and trade accordingly because
once you understand what's happening in
the market then
it just makes sense and it's one of
these things where you know it's a
double top okay
and you know right as soon as this bar
closes it's go time you know I know a
lot of people that will trade things
like this double top
and then they'll have a level okay well
then we gotta you know it's sort of you
know it's that m shape you know they got
well wait till we break down this you
know 11501 well this is your trade you
know as soon as this bar closes that
it's it this is your high it's most
likely going to hold and again where do
you place your stop it's just above that
high because if buyers come back in and
push it start to push it higher you
don't want to be in the trade anymore so
I mean you know your stop would be up
here at 12. you know you're getting
short somewhere around 08 for what you
know at least a minimum move down to you
know this area here this previous low
around 0102
right and and potentially lower when you
start seeing the big strong negative
um Deltas right the aggressive sellers
like this bar very strong negative Delta
8400 the bar traded only 20 000
contracts and almost half the volume you
know 40 of the volume is is negative
Delta that's telling you that there's
strong selling and then you know you
could let the trade run a little bit
further
so you know again I hope you like this
video there's no one trade so you know I
I get a lot of comments you know what's
your best setup you know this is one of
my favorite setups the only problem is
it just doesn't happen as often as I
would like it to happen you know I wish
it could happen every day but honestly
it doesn't happen every day but when I
see it you know it's something that
um it's like an automatic trade right
anytime I see one contract trade at the
high of the day
um
or at the low of the day you know that's
a trade I'm willing to take and you know
again if you don't know uh ninjatrader
one there's a free Ninja Trader
indicator that's included on ninjatrader
it's just um this one current day open
high low and that's plus that's how I
know this is the high today this green
line right the high of the day is an
important level it's
there's a reason why the markets you
know got a high and a low and when
you're up there at the high or down near
the low
you always want to be asking is this
going to be the high or is this going to
be the low and if you think it is it's
going to make for a great trade
opportunity because it's not uncommon
for the market to go from the high of
the day to the low of the day or from
the low of the day up to the high of the
day I mean it's doesn't always work out
you know that way sometimes it just goes
up 30 percent
from the low you know covering the day's
range but it has the potential to
potentially Traverse all the way to the
other side that's why I say if you can
have a reason
not trying to pick the higher the low
but if you have a reason to sell up near
the high or Buy near the low
based on the order flow go with it
so I hope you guys enjoyed this video
um you know be sure to like And
subscribe the channel and and keep
posting your comments keep them positive
and I'll see you guys on the next video
bye-bye